good morning everyone
and welcome to the 11th
meeting of the Ukraine defense contact
group
it's been nearly a year since this group
first met here right here at Remsen
and I hear that many of you refer to
this as the Ramstein forum
so it feels right that we're back here
to reaffirm our shared Unity
in our resolve
now this contact group started from a
place of moral clarity
we see Putin's War for what it is
and that is an unprovoked and
indefensible War of aggression
against a peaceful Sovereign and
Democratic Neighbors
Ukraine has been fighting bravely to
defend its people its sovereignty and
its freedom
in countries from around the world have
condemned Russia's atrocities and
aggression
stood up for an open world of rules and
rights
ladies and gentlemen more than a year
later
Ukraine is still standing strong
and our support has not wavered
and I'm proud of the progress that we
have made together
in total the members of this contact
group have provided more than 55 billion
dollars
in security assistance for Ukraine
that's a tenfold increase
since we first met
just in the past few months we've
provided the equipment and training to
support an additional nine armored for
gauge for for Ukraine
that has already strengthened Ukraine's
position on the battlefield
a European Consortium is donating
leopard tanks
countries continue to coordinate through
the contact group
on providing ammunition and maintenance
for those tanks
and so this contact group also provided
key air fence systems to protect these
rain skies and citizens in critical
infrastructure
that includes Patriot systems from the
United States and Germany and the
Netherlands
Santee from Italy and France
and may Sams from Canada and Norway
we've also improved training
statement
and the power of our industrial basis
and throughout we've demonstrated our
unity and determination
our common efforts have made a huge
difference
to Crane's Defenders on the battlefield
and they underscore just how badly
the Kremlin
is calculated
Putin thought that he could easily
topple each democratically elected
government
he thought that the wider world would
let him get away with it
he thought that our Unity would splinter
but he was wrong
on each and every account
they come together again at Ramstein
the world hears our voices
loud and clear
the world sees what we've achieved
together
Ukrainian military Stands Tall with
capability and courage
after more than a year of Russian
aggression
see
this contact group is as you maintenance
as ever
and more Global than ever
in our support for the forces of freedom
in Ukraine
hold strong and true
now I know that many of you have been
following the reports of unauthorized
disclosure of sensitive
and classified U.S material
I take this issue very seriously
and we will continue to work closely and
respectfully
with our deeply valued allies and
partners
as I've discussed this issue with our
allies and partners
I've been struck by your solidarity
and your commitment to reject efforts to
divide us
and we will not let anything
fracture our urine
now we're joining the gang by my good
friend Alexi resnikov of Ukraine
and Alexi we're looking forward to
hearing directly from you and your team
on the state of the battlefield and your
most urgent requirements
I also want to thank each country
joining us today
you've shown that nations of Goodwill
from around the world
reject Russia's cruelty immigration
and many of you have dug deep in your
own stocks
provide assistance to Ukraine
and some of our allies like Estonia and
Latvia
have donating more than one percent of
their GDP
Ukraine's cause
the European Union recently announced an
important initiative to ramp up the
industrial production of ammunition
throughout and through the work of our
national armaments directors directors
many more countries are also boosting
their production of the ammunition that
Ukraine so urgently needs
now earlier this week
United States announced our 36th
presidential drawdowns
of security assistance for Ukraine
valued at 325 million dollars
so we've now provided more than 35
billion dollars in security assistance
to Ukraine
since Russia's full-scale Invasion began
in this last package we've included more
ammunition for high bars
additional 155 millimeter and 105
millimeter artillery rounds
and important anti-harmor capabilities
and every step of the way we remain
focused on ensuring the accountability
of our assistance
along with our Ukrainian partners
now at today's contact groups meeting
we'll focus on three key issues
air defense
ammunition and enablers
Ukraine urgently needs our help to
Shield its citizens and infrastructure
and forces from Russia's missile threat
I also look forward to getting an update
from General agutto
our commander of the security assistance
group Ukraine on our work to build
Ukraine's armored combat car
we'll also hear an update on our
progress toward maintaining Ukraine's
equipment for the long term
so we all know what's at stake
for more than a year Ukraine's forces
have defended their country and their
fellow citizens
but they've also defended the basic
principle that autocrats
don't just get to assault their smaller
Neighbors
and the value and skill of Ukraine's
troops have inspired the world
from the Battle of Kiev to the
liberation of kirstan
Ukraine has shown again and again the
power of a free people fighting to
defend their rights
Ukraine will continue to fight just as
greatly
going forward
and all of us have come together to
stand up for Ukraine
before a world based on rules and rights
we reject Putin's Grand Vision of a
world where tyrants get to assault their
peaceful Neighbors
and try to impose self self-declared
spheres of influence
at gunpoint
ladies and gentlemen this contact group
is still Guided by Laurel clarity
together we will make sure that Ukraine
has what it needs to live in Freedom
together we will defend the rules-based
international border that keeps us all
secure
and together we will support Ukraine
for as long as it takes
for being here and I will pause and
let our friends in the media depart